in addition to all the other problems
that california has housing prices there
are higher than any place in the country
the median home price in the state of
california is now more than eight
hundred thousand dollars that's more
than double the nationwide median
in recent years because this really is a
problem leaders in california passed
dozens of bills they claim would fix the
problem governor jerry brown the last
guy signed 15 housing bills just in
2017.
last year gavin newsom signed 18
separate housing bills
did they work
not at all they did not work for the
people who live in california but they
weren't intended to work
for people who want to buy houses
instead those bills had one purpose
destroying suburban homes and replacing
them with high density housing
real estate developers make more money
when single family homes are leveled and
replaced with apartment complexes
obviously and real estate developers
happen to be major donors to the
democratic party of california and in
particular to gavin newsom for example
the real estate developer george marcus
was one of gavin newsom's biggest donors
in the recent recall election
so this week after surviving the recall
tragically gavin newsom rewarded those
real estate developers with the biggest
quote housing bill ever
newsome just signed a series of bills
most notably sb9 and sb10 that will
abolish the suburbs in the state of
california the state that invented the
suburbs those bills were endorsed by the
california building industry association
which represents quote interests of
builders and developers of housing and
commercial projects
they're about to be quite a few new
commercial projects in california
suburbs as the new york times put it
quote sb9 essentially ends single-family
zoning
property owners now have the state's
approval to convert any single-family
home in the state of california into a
four-unit apartment complex how is this
improving anyone's life
it won't
it means demolishing homes to put up
rental units at the behest of his donors
gavin newsom is turning the state of
california into a slum and it's not just
happening in california
recently oregon passed a statewide ban
on single family zoning this is insane
cities like minneapolis and sacramento
have begun to allow multi-family
dwellings on single-family lots
crowding a problem anyone think
only the government of china by the way
appears to be doing anything to rein in
real estate developers quote housing
should be for living in not for
speculation said the president of china
recently we hate to quote the president
of china but in this case he is right
we know that because one of the largest
and most leveraged real estate companies
in the world the china-based evergrand
group is collapsing and china has given
no indication they're interested in
bailing out evergrand
meanwhile in this country real estate
companies don't just get bailouts they
get to write the laws they get to wreck
your neighborhood
in many parts of america they be able to
demolish the home next door and turn it
into an apartment complex
that's great
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else